[Music]
could this be the technology that takes
future travel back to where concord last
went
almost 20 years ago aircraft which
promised to transport passengers across
the atlantic
in half the time they're used to travel
is following in the footsteps of
celebrities in the rich
who enjoyed the first days of supersonic
commercial travel
now there's a promise it'll be back
supersonic is back
back in a big way it's here to stay and
it's going to be more mainstream than
it's ever been before
we can reduce the cost of supersonic by
75
which means this is going to be
available to tens of millions of
passengers
united airlines has agreed in principle
to buy jets from a denver based start-up
boom technology
bringing back supersonic passenger
travel which ended with the last
concorde flight in 2003.
for nearly 30 years the aircraft which
used much more fuel than regular planes
and was criticized for its environmental
impact was only accessible to those with
very very deep pockets
but united believes the demand is there
we see strong demand between london
heathrow and new york
as soon as this product is available
lots of people want to go concord was
permanently grounded
three years after the aircraft's only
crash which killed 113 people
but the planes still hold a special
place in history
this one of the most viewed exhibits at
the national air and space museum in
virginia
concord failed in part because it was so
expensive to run
and the big question for the future is
where the supersonic passenger travel
really can be commercially viable the
museum's director says there are hurdles
to climb reducing noise and fuel
consumption
but new technology will help the car
that you drive today
is far more fuel efficient than the car
you drove
even 10 or 15 years ago so the same
thing is happening
in in aviation where there are new
technologies new
um economies of scale new efficiencies
that really do change that dynamic
united airlines will be aiming to
deliver its supersonic program whilst
meeting its pledge to become carbon
neutral by 2050.
a prototype is due to make its first
journey in the next year
michelle clifford sky news virginia